merci à tous je voudrais pour commencer
parce qu'une campagne électorale c'est
cela vous parlez d'une rencontre au pas
une rencontre mise en scène pas une
rencontre avec les caméras de télévision
non une rencontre une rencontre d'une
dame qui à 80 ans cette dame est veuve
retraitée évidemment et c'est damas l'a
demandé à son fils de me mettre sur le
petit bout de papier qui est là
exactement quelle a été l'évolution de
ses impôts depuis 2012 et je vais vous
dire à la fin pourquoi cette dame m'a
fait ce petit papier en 2012 cette dame
qui s'appelle cécile paient sans un euro
d'impôt sur le revenu sans anovo en 2013
cette dame a eu à payer 550 2 euros
d'impôt sur le revenu
retraités retraités donc pas
d'augmentation de salaire pas de prime
de noël pas d'heures supplémentaires le
même revenu en 2014
elle a eu à payer 692 euros d'impôt sur
le revenu et en 2015
elle a reçu un avis sur lequel étaient
marqués 751 euros d'impôt sur le revenu
mais mais non non non dans le même envoi
il y avait une lettre du gouvernement
lui disons que cette année
exceptionnellement elle aurait droit à
une ristourne de 220 euros et qu'au lieu
de payer 751 euros d'impôt sur le revenu
elle aurait à payer que 531 euros
d'impôt sur le revenu mais cette dame
elle a eu envie de sortir son stylo pas
pour dire merci au gouvernement et à
françois hollande elle a eu envie
d'écrire sur ce papier parce qu'elles
gardent de tout précisément
précieusement
elle a eu envie de m'écrire que cette
dame qui paient 101 euros aujourd'hui
elle paye cinq fois plus et que tous les
mois tous les mois ce sont 30 euros
qu'elle a en moins sur son compte parce
qu'elle doit payer davantage d'impôts et
son fils m'a dit que ce qu'il a fait
réagir c'est parce qu'elle a bien en
mémoire le discours de celui
qui était candidat à la présidence de la
république et qui avait dit dans un
numéro d'artiste ou d'acteurs de théâtre
dans ce fameux discours du bourget ne
vous inquiétez pas mon ennemi c'est la
finance seuls les riches paieront plus
d'impôts
cette dame ne savait pas qualité riche
et tous les jours elle a moins pour
vivre à cause du gouvernement socialiste
jamais jamais françois hollande ne fera
croire aujourd'hui en faisant des
ristournes parce que les élections
régionales approchent
parce que la présidentielle approche
jamais françois hollande ne rendra aux
français ce qu'il a volé aux français en
leur prenant un maximum d'impôt jamais
il ne le fera mais en attendant celui
qui a abaissé la france celui qui a fait
mal aux français
celui-là est tenté d'entraîner tout le
monde dans sa chute
j'ai une autre rencontre en tête c'est à
boulogne sur mer
très tôt un matin des ouvriers qui après
le travail des pêcheurs près par le
poisson qui sera vendu dans les grandes
surfaces mais aussi dans les
poissonneries et cela en rentrant très
tôt le matin je voyais bien qu'il
n'avait pas le sourire en voyant rentrée
pourquoi oh pas parce que je suis un élu
des républicains mais parce que sur mon
front ses marques et politiques et en
définitive cela correspondait à une
entreprise me dit vous savez ils ont
commencé tôt ils ont beaucoup de boulot
sont pas très souriant dit non non c'est
pas ça la raison
la raison c'est qu'ils ont voté pour
nous pour nicolas sarkozy en 2007 et que
ont vu très clairement très clairement
que quand il travaillait plus ils
gagnaient plus dans cette entreprise
on est toujours resté à 41 heures parce
qu'ils aient du travail en 2012
certains d'entre eux ont fait le choix
de françois hollande mais il n'avait pas
vu il n'avait pas bien entendu que ce
serait la fin des heures supplémentaires
défiscalisées et cela
quand vous faites de la politique et que
vous les voyez il n'est pas certain
qu'ils ont envie de vous parler parce
qu'il met aujourd'hui tout le monde dans
le même sac même si c'est injuste c'est
nous qui avons porté les heures
supplémentaires défiscalisées et je suis
fier d'avoir été nominé aux côtés de
françoise nicolas apporter les heures
supplémentaires défiscalisées
nous nous sommes battus pour les garder
mais aujourd'hui celui qui leur a volé
le fruit de leur travail
le fruit des heures supplémentaires
défiscalisées c'est françois hollande
voilà pourquoi aujourd'hui les français
veulent tourner la page de françois
hollande est dans ma région c'est
exactement la même chose
les élus qui sont ici les militants de
cette grande et belle région nord pas de
calais picardie savent vraiment ce que
l'on entend partout aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui les habitants de la région
nord pas de calais picardie veulent
tourner la page du système socialiste
parce que dans cette région qui a une
histoire intimement lié au travail est
la valeur travail
ils ont laissé faire du mal aux petits
comme on me l'a dit sur un marché du
bassin minier de la même façon cette
valeur travail qui est incontournable
cette valeur travail qui permet aussi de
s'élever dans la société de donner un
avenir à ses enfants
cette valeur travail elle a été abîmé
par une région qui a toujours été gérée
par le parti socialiste et qui ont
laissé la région rongée par le chômage
de cette façon je pense que nous pouvons
nous aussi montré que la valeur travail
nous n'avons pas seulement portée en
2007 qu'elle reste notre valeur
cardinale notre boussole la valeur que
l'on met en avant permanence parce que
nous nous respectons ceux qui ont
travaillé
ceux qui travaillent ce qui donne du
travail et ceux qui recherchent du
travail
c'est la raison pour laquelle je suis
persuadé que nous pouvons faire la
preuve dans deux mois même pas dans deux
ans dans deux mois que nous sommes
capables de changer le quotidien de nos
concitoyens et notamment de faire
reculer l'assistanat
prenez l'exemple du rsa le rsa je le
sais bien
c'est la responsabilité des départements
et il ya aujourd'hui des expériences
audacieuses ambitieuses courageuse
je pense notamment l'expérience d'eric
ciotti dans le département des
alpes-maritimes
je pense aussi à ce que fait sébastien
lecornu dans le département de l'eure
mais je sais aussi que dans de très
nombreux départements
on a aujourd'hui les pires difficultés à
pouvoir redonner une activité redonner
une formation à celles et ceux qui sont
au rsa c'est déjà difficile de financer
le rsa comme dans le département du nord
où les prédécesseurs de jean rené lecerf
avait financer le rsa sur onze mois
seulement
ce n'est pas qu'ils avaient oublié
qu'une année contre 12 mois c'est tout
simplement que leur budget était un
sincère et que pour le présenter il
avait dû truqués le budget du conseil
général socialiste
alors aujourd'hui avec des départements
qui ne peuvent pas faire beaucoup plus
la région peut en travaillant main dans
la main avec les départements proposer à
chacun des bénéficiaires du rsa une
formation pas une formation bidon pas un
stage parking de proposer le véritable
activité de financer un chantier école
et un chantier d'insertion
je propose que dans la région
nord-pas-de-calais picardie les trois
cent mille bénéficiaires du rsa nous
soit présenté proposé par le conseil
général est que ce soit le conseil
régional qui propose à chacun d'entre
eux une activité une formation un retour
vers l'emploi
comme le dit la loi je suis prêt à
tendre la main à deux reprises à deux
reprises de donner leur chance à ceux
qui sont éloignés de l'emploi depuis des
années mais je le dis aussi clairement
nous croyons tout et tout ce qu'une
société se bâtit avec des droits et des
devoirs avec des contreparties si par
deux fois on ne se présente pas aux
convocations
si par deux fois on refuse cette main
tendue les départements pourront alors
suspendre le rsa
je ne vous dis pas d'attendre deux ans
je vous dis que c'est dans deux mois que
nous pouvons le faire et à ceux qui
s'interrogeraient pour savoir mais est
ce qu'ils font vraiment le faire et bien
je vous dis en disant tout avant en
risquant peut-être si certains ne
veulent pas entendre ce message
si certains sont mécontents avant et
bien si vous avez les mécontents avant
vous n'aurez pas peur de les avoir après
c'est la garantie que nous mettrons en
oeuvre tout notre projet pour sortir de
l'assistanat
nous avons aussi et jean-pierre
l'expliquait ce matin avec le projet
vocation aussi à renforcer la sécurité
et l'autorité si malmenée depuis
maintenant trois ans alors bien
évidemment nous avons toutes et tous en
tête la terrible responsabilité de
madame taubira
mais c'est bel et bien le président de
la république il a nommé et nous voulons
faire la preuve aussi que dans une
région ce qui est de la compétence de la
région les trains régionaux
les gars mais aussi les lycées pour
faire reculer les raquettes et les
trafics de drogue
même si certains pensent que ce n'est
pas le rôle de la région l'insécurité
est un problème dans nos régions nous
devons donc prendre la mesure de ce
problème et y apporter des solutions
concrètes
nous mettrons des agents de sécurité
dans tous les ter passé 20 heures et il
y aura des caméras de vidéosurveillance
dans l'ensemble des trains régionaux
dans l'ensemble des gares et dans
l'ensemble des lycéens
vous comprenez pourquoi dans ma région
comme ailleurs au temps de nos
concitoyens en veulent autant aux
dirigeants du parti socialiste
alors je le dis à celles et ceux qui
s'amusent avec un feuilleton de
politique fiction comprenez bien que
celles et ceux qui dans ma région nous
ont plongés dans un tel déclin cela il
n'est pas question il ne sera jamais
question de faire alliance avec eux
entre les deux tours pour remporter
cette élection j'ai appris que c'est en
étant fidèle à ses électeurs
c'est en étant fidèle à ses valeurs que
l'on remporte une élection ça n'est pas
en renouant avec les délices
empoisonnées de la quatrième république
les magouilles les manoeuvres très peu
pour moi je le dis clairement ma liste
et mon projet seront les mêmes au
premier et au deuxième tour
n'ayez pas peur ayez confiance c'est
comme ça que nous remporterons
l'élection en nord-pas-de-calais
picardie
et je ne suis pas plus inquiet quand
juin 2012
en juin 2012 quand c'était si difficile
et quant à l'époque madame le pen
m'avait placé sur sa liste noire
cela voulait dire notamment que madame
le pen entre les deux tours des
élections législatives à saint-quentin
appelé clairement à voter socialiste
pour me faire battre
je suis devant vous en tant que député
j'étais réélu parce que le su rester
fidèle à mes valeurs et les magouilles
elles viennent du front national alors
parlons de ce front national si élevé
dans notre région pourquoi parce que
c'est dans notre région qu'il ya
certainement le plus de colère le plus
de peur de la misère également dans mon
département de l'aisne comme dans
l'ensemble de la région et je veux
parler de ce front national qui se
nouent re qui se nourrit que des
problèmes
sa vocation c'est de surfer sur les
problèmes ne demandez pas au front
national de régler les problèmes les
problèmes c'est son fond de commerce
les problèmes c'est sa raison de vivre
le jour où il n'y a plus de problème
le front national ne sera plus jamais au
niveau où ils se situent aujourd'hui
c'est notre responsabilité à nous comme
tout élu qui se respecte même si c'est
dur de dire la vérité d'apporter des
solutions aux problèmes
madame le pen elle certainement pas
quand le matin elle allume la radio et
qu'il ya des mauvaises nouvelles
c'est une bonne journée pour elle elle
se nourrit que des problèmes
notre vocation c'est de régler les
problèmes
yann est en permanence en totale
contradiction
elle nous dit qu'une région ne peut rien
faire contre le chômage
bien sûr que si elle peut agir par
l'apprentissage pour les jeunes et en
remettant aussi en activité les
bénéficiaires du rsa et en trouvant une
solution à tous ces entrepreneurs qui
vous disent je cherche mais je ne trouve
pas cent vingt mille offres d'emplois
non pourvus dans ma région et plus de
500 mille demandeurs d'emploi en nous
attaquant à ce problème nous ne
passerons pas le chômage mais on pourra
le fait reculer en matière d'exemplarité
le front national veut nous donner des
leçons mais dans le département de
l'aisne où il ya une mairie qui est
passé au front national villers
cotterêts la première décision du maire
front national alors que la vie est dure
pour ses concitoyens
ça a été de s'augmenter l'indemnité de
maire d'auch 15%
elle est belle l'exemplarité quand elle
est mise en avant par le front national
est la deuxième décision
ça a été d'augmenter le prix de la
cantine pour les plus démunis parce que
c'est cela qu'il faut bien entendre
beaucoup de ceux qui sont dans la misère
et dans la colère se disent pas
ras-le-bol bien souvent ou parce qu'ils
sont enfermés dans leurs peurs se disent
qu'ils vont se tourner vers le front
national qu'il n'oublie pas qu'en grèce
comme ailleurs
à chaque fois que les populistes ont
pris le pouvoir ceux qui ont souffert le
plus en premier ce sont les petits et
les plus fragiles
la sortie de l'euro de madame le pen ça
veut dire très clairement que ce sont
les économies des retraités qui
partiront et ceux qui à chaque fois font
le plus le frais de cette politique de
malheur ce sont les plus fragiles comme
à villers cotterêts
dans mon département quant à la
préférence régionale qu'ils veulent
mettre en avant si c'est pour que les
marchés publics favorisent entreprises
locales ça s'appelle enfoncer des portes
ouvertes mais en revanche il y a une
préférence que ne reniera jamais le
front national vous en avez l'exemple
avec la famille le pen
vous en avez l'exemple maintenant ravier
à marseille vous aviez le père vous avez
le fils vous avez aussi l'exemple dans
ma région
la vocation du front national c'est une
préférence familiale est intolérable aux
yeux de celles et ceux qui sont propres
de leur part
tout n'est que mensonge pour tromper
profiter des peurs exploiter les colères
ce sont à la fois des amateurs on le
voit bien
et ce sont des menteurs et face à cela
face à ce discours de facilité qui est
le leur nous devons tenir un discours de
vérité nous devons tenir un discours
quand je parle de la région au travail
pour nord-pas de calais picardie de dire
qu'il ne faut pas mentir il n'y a que
par le travail qu'on peut se construire
que par le travail que l'on peut créer
des richesses et mieux les partager
alors je vous le dis mes amis il ya plus
important que nos ambitions personnelles
il y à la fois notre action les
résultats que nous pouvons délivrer dès
le début de l'année 2016 l'espoir que
nous devons redonner il n'ya que nous
que nous qui pouvons rassembler les
français
nous pouvons rassurer les français qui
pouvons les sortir de leurs peurs qui
pouvant aussi éteindre leur colère cela
nous demandera des efforts des efforts
d'union et de solidarité entre nous des
efforts aussi de remise en cause par
rapport à un certain nombre de
politiques que nous avons pu mener mais
je voudrais vous dire que les français
comme les habitants de la région et ils
veulent du travail et ils veulent de
l'autorité ça n'est pas si compliqué que
ça la politique
et n'ayons pas peur des réactions des
médias n'ayons pas peur des sondages
parce que celles et ceux qui votent
c'est vous qui êtes ici c'est le peuple
rassemblé c'est cette majorité
silencieuse qui s'exprime dans les urnes
et pas seulement dans les sondages
vous connaissez vous connaissez tous ma
région
vous connaissez tous notre belle région
vous savez qu'elle a souffert qu'elle a
terriblement souffert
vous savez aussi qu'elle est grande
qu'elle est généreuse qu'elle est
travailleuse et c'est aussi une région
qui ne se résignent pas comme cela ça
n'est pas une région qui baisse les bras
ça n'est pas non plus je vous le dis une
région qui veut être montré du doigt à
partir du 13 décembre
c'est une région qui a connu tellement
de malheurs qu'elle n'a pas besoin et
qu'elle ne veut pas des marchands de
malheurs que sont les populistes et les
démagogues du front national alors
et je les mesures et depuis tout à
l'heure dans cette salle et dans les
couloirs
j'ai conscience j'ai bien conscience que
je suis que nous sommes avec mes amis de
la région qui sont ici présents que nous
sommes à la pointe que nous sommes à
l'avant-garde d'un combat que nous
menons tous ce combat c'est le combat
pour la république
c'est le combat pour les valeurs
républicaines c'est le combat pour
l'idéal républicain
le combat pour notre région c'est le
même combat que nous menons pour la
france une france qui ne se résignent
pas qui ne se referme pas et y aura à
nouveau confiance en elle
c'est ce combat là qui nous oppose en
permanence au front national
c'est ce combat là que je porte en votre
nom alors si comme moi vous croyez à ce
combat si comme moi vous aimez votre
pays vous aimez ma région
alors dans ces cas là mes amis au
travail aidez nous aidez nous à faire en
sorte que la région nord pas de calais
picardie renoue avec l'espoir
en attendant de montrer la voie à notre
pays